now if you have eczema another name for
that would be dermatitis or atopic
dermatitis I have a very good remedy for
you this is a skin condition which you
have extreme dryness you maybe have a
red rash or it could be very very itchy
but of course if you look this up on
Wikipedia it says there's no known cause
and no known cure but there is steroids
but they have side effects but if you
dig a little bit further you'll find a
lot of research that will show you that
there is some promising effects from a
very powerful natural remedy that which
I want to talk about and based on the
effectiveness of this remedy apparently
this condition is a problem with
what's called essential fatty acids
could be that your diet is not right or
it could be a genetic problem that keeps
you kind of more susceptible to having
this deficiency now since I've been
really into this deep dive into DNA I
noticed this one gene that could easily
give someone eczema and if they don't
know this then they're not going to know
the epigenetic things that they can do
they might then be persuaded that
there's nothing you can do and you're
just going to have to live with it but
that's not true the mechanism is this
the body just is not being able to
convert
certain essential fatty acids into the
form that the skin needs to function
correctly and primarily the sebaceous
glands that are in the skin to release
the oil and when this happens you get a
severeness in dry skin you get a lack of
blood flow or capillary flow to your
skin and you get a severe dehydration on
top of that with a little inflammation
and slow wound healing so if you injure
yourself it takes a lot longer to heal
and so that's really what it is so what
is the remedy well you want to take
something called GLA and that stands for
gamma
lenolenic acid but let's just call it
GLA now out of all the things that has
the highest amount of this GLA it is
black currant seed oil in fact black
currant seed oil has two to three times
the amount of gla then evening primrose
oil which has actually been known to
have high levels of gla but this black
currant seed oil also is high in
omega-3 fatty acids or at least the
precursor ala and that is
anti-inflammatory too it also has many
other things one being thymoquinone
which helps decrease inflammation of the
skin it has lauric acid which can help
decrease a microbial infection to the
skin it actually improves the immune
system to the skin and the research on
this is quite amazing apparently in one
study it was as effective as steroid
creams and even more effective than
another common cream they use for eczema
called Eucerin cream so this is what you
do you would buy some black currant seed
oil okay and you put like five drops in
your hands and you rub it together so
it's nice and warm and then you apply it
to your skin it's that simple you can
also try to find it in a cream but you
can just use an oil too and I would also
at the same time take black currant seed
oil as a supplement you can get them in
pearls or you can just put a few drops
of that in your water and drink that
down I'm not sure what that would taste
like but it's one option all right so
there's your short video of I think a
very effective remedy for eczema but if
you haven't seen my other video in eggs
a month which gives you another angle on
this I put that up right here check it
out